a long time member obviously been very
good to the Meetup over the years
and previously before he became cool
he used to be a music photographer
and he actually toured of a bunch of
bands if you want to see his work he's
in Chris Payne's oral history of emo
yes please welcome Rick so first of all
hi everybody I'm Rick or Ricky my
pronouns are he and him
I'm going to actually kick us off or
kick this off my talk
by sharing a story
of a really great flop of ours
so I used to I've run a few data teams
in uh throughout my life
maybe about 10 years ago probably around
the same time Jad was talking about of
when we made these shirts uh for the r
Meetup
I was at a music company
and we had an awesome data science team
there was this astrophysicist on my team
who taught me these really awesome stuff
about time series and random forests and
all sorts of stuff I didn't know before
then
and
because we're in the music industry and
the music is a hits business
will you set out to predict hits
we had a wealth of data we had a bunch
of data from I don't even need to
mention the companies but you can
imagine all the really awesome companies
out there where you can get some
streaming data you can scrape some data
off the internet we build these amazing
models uh we even went through the
process of starting to Pat in some of
these
and it took us I don't know how many
months to develop it maybe two three
four months
when we're ready right we were tuning
them going through we were thinking we
got some pretty good results and we're
ready to Showcase it it's a small
startup there's about 15 of us so we're
all gathered around a monitor that looks
kind of similar to the one here in front
of me right but it's up on the wall
and we're showing the results of these
models where we're showing them live and
it's like like we're uh we're doing a
little bit of like back testing right
here's what the model is going to Output
of these artists that are going to blow
up and we start to actually pull up
these artists and we're like whoa so
something like 80 of the like the top 20
artists that our model predicted had all
blown up and had flown under the radar
that's amazing right we're like well the
entire you know like all 15 of us
celebrating like crazy
uh and someone's like really excited
something and all sincerity asks
what are we gonna do with this
and we're like what do you mean what are
we gonna do with this we thought you'd
know
and I kid you not when I say we built
this amazing model and for ages it's
just sat there on a Shelf
right because we didn't actually figure
out what happens after we make this
really awesome model
right so today I'm going to talk a
little bit about all the parts of data
that have nothing to do with data
all the data work that's necessary
before and after
but really just focusing on like the one
most important question uh that every
essentially every team needs to answer
which is this it's what work should my
team do in order to ensure success
now I see is the word team here because
it's an easy it's an easy phrase to use
for a lot of my career I was a team of
one a lot of folks I talked to I know
are still teams of one this this
everything I'm going to say tonight or
today applies whether you are a team of
one or a team of 20 whether you have
multiple teams all working together and
it's really a team of teams I'm just
using this term pretty Loosely here
um so just a little bit about myself uh
so Rick went through that I'm currently
working as an SVP of data at a company
called Interra
I've been in this industry for about two
decades now I used to head up the data
strategy and insights department at the
farmer's dog uh if you watch any of the
the Super Bowl commercials they have
that amazing dog commercial that just
got nominated for an Emmy this week
which is just amazing
uh and then prior to that was VP of data
at a company called video that was
recent acquired by gamma and the orchard
which is acquired by Sony most folks
here have never heard of The Orchard but
if you listen to anything on Spotify or
iTunes there's about a 70 chance that
our pipes actually put that music there
and then prior to that I worked at many
other companies uh some bi companies I
did data product management uh at a
large Insurance firm and a whole lot of
other stuff
but uh let's clarify some terms really
quickly
things on the left are not the same as
the things on the right
this term data product management has
come into fashion and I really like to
distinguish it from the concept of
managing data as a product very similar
terms they're not at all the same thing
managing data as a product is about
giving data the uh the respect it
deserves and actually managing it
correctly data product management is
about what we do with data what it
enables us to accomplish that we can't
otherwise accomplish
but let's also define success here uh so
the success of any team
but by the way just really quickly I got
a little bit nerdier on this talk given
the given the nature of the audience
here trying to get a little bit uh mathy
but I think we can define success of a
team with these two basic concepts right
which is the value of our work and the
value of our work relative to you know
whatever we call the investment in it
right so we're investing our own time uh
we're exciting we're investing our own
time we're investing efforts we're
generally we're renting machines
somewhere to run stuff or we're buying
really expensive machines
and so we really want to figure out does
this work generate some sort of value
above some threshold
um
in Industry you generally measure this
as some sort of dollars in dollars out
in Academia you might measure it as
something around uh papers published
But ultimately you're investing your own
energy your own time all the things you
could be doing with your life instead of
doing this and you're asking is it worth
it
right so I'm going to jump around here a
little bit and I appreciate you all
bearing with me as we do this
but we want to ask the question of how
do we measure success how do we know if
we are succeeding and so
very simply if we uh if the total value
we're producing is above our threshold
and if the total value relative to the
investment is above the other threshold
we're going to call that success
but really what we care about is how do
we ensure success right this is how we
Define it how do we ensure it
we're going to tap into that
mathematical part of our brain and we're
going to flip it and say well let's
assume failure and what went wrong and
we're going to analyze it from there
right so assume that we're failing
assume that our team is not succeeding
what's happening one of those two
thresholds are not being met right
um and actually even before that excuse
me we could say either we're doing great
work or we're not doing great work if
we're not doing great work I'm just
going to say that all of that is outside
the scope of this talk right if we're
not doing great work you know there's
probably some disconnect between the
capabilities work we'll keep that
outside of this but really what we care
about is assuming that we are doing
great work but yet our team is still not
succeeding why are we not succeeding
right think about all so going back to
that story at the very beginning we did
amazing work we build amazing models
right 80 of the top 20 results of that
model actually were successes
and yet it was completely useless right
I would not say that we did great work I
would say we created great math models
that accomplish nothing
right and that's a that's a very
um
it's very humbling
idea
and so if we are doing great work
and yet we do and then we're failing
right we're assuming failure here we're
trying to understand why we're failing
one of these two things are true we're
either
um
either the total value of our works not
hitting our threshold or the value to
effort ratio is not there right
essentially like there's no Roi either
there's not enough value in our work or
there's not enough return on investment
of our work
and we can actually start breaking these
through
so if our work just as overall is not
producing enough value
right it's either not getting used
or the work's getting used but it's not
producing enough value by itself
right this latter one's a little bit
easier if it's not producing enough
value what it means is essentially what
we thought was valuable we were just
wrong we had some estimate before we got
started with the work we decided we
would do this turns out we were
completely wrong
or we're actually right about it it just
hasn't been integrated correctly and
we're going to talk a little more about
handoffs and integrating it and how
challenging that is
more more often than not what happens is
data science work or data work as a
whole ends up not getting used
I'm sure show of hands how many people
here have actually built something that
ended up on a shelf in a new mailbox no
one ever used it right we all look
around it's like literally everyone's
raising their hands right now right
um
that happens for a variety of different
reasons people don't know how to use our
work or the work arrived way too late
we don't know how to integrate it
they have other things going on right it
just wasn't really a priority or they
never needed it in the first place right
all these different reasons why we build
something and no one uses it
this is all assuming that uh the work
itself is not producing value
alternatively maybe the work the the
work itself is fine but the ratio
relative to how much effort we put in is
off right and therefore when we look at
our team as a whole we feel like our
team is not succeeding meaning we're
putting in all this time all this effort
we're getting good stuff done but just
not enough of it that's normally how I
think about right if you look at data
science teams a lot of really great data
science teams produce an amazing
results one time and there's this one
major project that they've gotten done
and that's about it and this one major
project pretty much takes up the whole
year
or sometimes you'll have one really
great project there may be like two or
three little trinkles of something
throughout the year and that's about it
and then year over year and when you
look at the plans that they make for the
year okay well what are we going to do
next year we're going to do these four
really big things and then the year
comes to an end and they did maybe one
of them
so generally that looks like the work
we're doing is taking longer than we
thought
and this one there's a variety of
reasons why this happens
we don't know when to stop the work
right and this is like we're aiming for
model performance it's way too high we
don't have a clear definition of what
we're actually what's in and out of
scope
we're taking on the wrong massive
projects we're doing these really giant
projects and it's not even the right one
to do there's something else we could
have done there's other value there I'm
not going to go through and read this
entire list
but you can imagine there's a whole lot
of reasons of why our work fails and we
start getting a sense of if we're
failing there's all these variety of
reasons of why we're failing
and at the at the heart of it right
there's a few core things here first of
all
whenever we're doing work there's always
the opportunity cost of all of the other
work we could have done instead
especially when it comes to data work
there is so much that you can do with
data
that to do the wrong thing
is um
it almost hurts sometimes right I think
of like what we could have been doing
instead
right and then the major problem with
all of this is the fact that there's
this disconnect between
Us in the data in the data world and
then to ecosystem in which we're living
of where our work integrates
and we're either not understanding words
integrating strongly enough or we're
handing it off and that handoff is
flopping somewhere
cool so let's dive into this just a
little bit more here
oops let's go all the way back
all right by the way I'm using uh I'm
trying I'm gonna use Miro here to to
present I've never done this before so
uh thanks for for bearing with me on
this
you'll probably have seen something like
this at some point in your life right uh
you're trying to figure out what work to
do you think of all these ideas every
blue dot every dot on this graph
represents some work that you could be
doing and you've got
you put your value on one side you put
how much effort it's going to take to do
it on another side and you start
figuring out what you're going to do
right and ultimately if you're doing
work you start from this corner and you
work your way all the way up to actually
don't do that corner that corner never
do it right if you use up this whole
Corner think of more ideas don't keep
going that way right but generally
you're working in that corner and
you know you plot all this out optimally
you'll say oops you'll try to stay like
just stay in that corner right do only
the work in that corner
so going back to why data teams fail
at the heart of it right you think of
all those reasons in in that little mind
map at the heart of it we're essentially
doing the wrong work what do we mean by
doing the wrong work it means that we've
taken on one of those guys up over there
when we should have been doing one of
these down over here
right that's essentially what we mean
when we say doing the wrong work we're
doing work that didn't have the value we
thought or Worse we thought one of those
folks was all the way over there that
had a ton of value but it didn't right
or we thought it was down here and it
was really easy effort but it turns out
it's much higher effort
right generally if we've done the wrong
work it means we've messed up one of
these two things right we've estimated
the effort wrong or we've estimated the
value wrong
right so how do we actually go about
doing this uh these all these uh
initiative names by the way they're just
made up words
you probably put together a spreadsheet
like this at some point in your life or
maybe you've seen one of these put
together you go around you think of all
the ideas you want to do you put
together how much value how much effort
people call it different things
um
return investment complexity what have
you
and ultimately you calculate some sort
of score
I love this in the concept of data
science
because what we're actually doing when
we're thinking about what work to do if
you look carefully what we have is we
have an optimization problem
we have this these inputs which are
value and effort
and we're going to output something
right essentially it's a ranking problem
we're going to rank all of these
however
this is where I think a lot of us uh
oh sorry so essentially any team given
that you have limited resources if you
have infinite resources you can get all
the work done right but if you have a
limited amount of time limit amount of
resources you need to essentially draw a
line along your graph that says I'm
going to do the stuff below this you
know beyond this line the stuff that has
high value relative to the effort I'm
going to put in anything beyond that is
outside of the scope of my resources if
you want to give me more resources sure
we'll go get more stuff done we can move
that line back but without the amount of
resources we need that's that's the only
work we're going to do
ah
but there's a big problem
it doesn't look like this
what it really looks like is something
like this
meaning
and each one of these blue clouds is
let's call it an initiative a piece of
work
we don't actually know what the value of
the work is
and we have no way of knowing what the
effort is and I say that kind of loosely
but not really at all right we can guess
what that what the effort is
and so one thing I would really love to
invite everybody here to think of is
when we think of the value and the
effort of a piece of work when you're
looking at a work and you're thinking
it's valuable or how much effort it's
going to take
to think of those as random variables
they are in fact random variables from a
chaotic process they're stochastic in
nature
and what we want to do and in order for
data science to succeed is to be able to
reduce those error bars right to
estimate them more accurately to
estimate the effort estimate the value
more accurately
right and a lot of times you'll see us
if you read some product management
blogs they're going to tell you
something of like using these three
column uh way of prioritizing work right
and they'll tell you oh it's the value
it's the effort but also the confidence
right how much confidence you have in
your estimates right but we work in data
science we get a little smarter than
that and we can recognize that
confidence overall in the whole thing
doesn't really make sense because this
what does that even mean
on value itself we have confidence and
on effort itself we have confidence and
each of those are random variables is
not the entire it's not the the entire
ecosystem
right and so I really just stick with
these two things and there's a whole
other aspect of how do you even figure
out what the value is how do you figure
out what the effort is
but oops
I lost my presentation
let's try let's see
all right
and so
one of the big challenges is if we're
unsure about what exactly the value is
and what exactly the effort is
well we don't even know whether or not
we should do it and whether or not we
should prioritize it
right if we have one if this big old
blob of a thing
normally what happens is we say it's
over here right most initiatives that
failed I'll bet you anything if you look
back on it we're going to say this is
where it was at right before we started
we said it's over here and that's where
it ended
if you look look back at any initiative
that you've undertaken that has sat on a
shelf or that just really wasn't a
success we hoped it would or took way
longer
think about where you would have plotted
it beforehand that's your prior
you did the work that's your posterior
and then where you plot it
and ultimately what we want to do is we
want to be able to resolve from this big
old hazy thing of a cloud down to a more
precise estimate and if we can get that
precise estimate then we can focus on
doing the right work overall if you
think of the expected value of our
entire team of our entire work of us
over the course of a year five years
whatever you want to put that as
we're maximizing that
and we're doing it so and and we can
actually do it algorithmically in a
really fun way which is we could take
that big old blob of a thing and instead
of going through and undertaking that
project
what we decide to do is we take on a
small little bit of it and the purpose
of that project is not to complete it
the purpose of that project is to get
enough information so as to decide
should we continue doing it or not we're
trying to deduce what is the true value
of the work what is the true effort of
the work and so we want to do just
enough
um sorry I'm using the word work twice
but we want to do just enough work to
understand how much effort how much
value this I'm going to call it a
project how much work effort and value
this project actually has
and as we start doing a little bit more
and a little bit more and a little bit
more the uncertainty starts to get
narrower and narrower and narrower
right and so what we're trying to do
ultimately is we've got this big old
cloud of a mess
and we're trying to figure out is it
going to be above or below
that vector right is it going to be work
that we should do or shouldn't do we're
trying to do a little bit of work to
understand that and if we continue to do
this with each piece of our of our
projects well we end up when we look
back at all the work we've done we've
realized that we've built a team that is
highly successful and accomplishing a
lot of really great things build in
amazing models that those models get
used and those models get integrated
into really great work
I have this concept called the two-day
rule it's a little bit cheeky but I mean
it very sincerely which is anytime you
take on a project for the very first
time an Initiative for the very first
time they've never done before never
plan on spending more than two days on
it
if you think about how many works we
plan out that we plan for a month right
so someone comes to us our marketing
team comes to us it's like hey could you
do this uh you know whatever some really
important piece of work for us yeah of
course it'll take me about three weeks
four weeks and then it ends up taking
about two months
right if we think it's going to take two
days it's probably going to take
a week maybe two right and we want to
keep it as narrow as possible the first
time we do it and the second time as
well until we really understand what is
the value and effort of the work
um
running out of time so I'm going to go
through this really fast handoffs Focus
really heavily on handoffs I'm gonna
jump through this pretty fast but
handoffs is the other really important
part of datawork our work it's a very
humbling idea to recognize that our work
in itself does not have Direct Value the
value comes from integrating and
partnering with someone else and our
work we need to do something with it we
produce a really awesome model what are
we going to do with it if we don't know
what that what that is then we can't
actually produce the value of our work
and so we need to really figure that
part out
um and then lastly having these talks in
order to really understand
what it is that our work is doing and
where it's integrating
we need to have some really
important conversations with the folks
that we're interacting with right and
this is really challenging for some
folks in data and what I found is
there's people in data who freaking love
it right and they're really integrated
deeply into all the other aspects of the
context of the data let's say and then
there's other folks who are in data
because they never want to have those
conversations
uh and to those folks specifically of
which I was one of those for quite a
while I'd say learn to learning to have
these conversations learning to really
deduce what is the value of the work can
help ensure the success of yourself as a
team and a bus as a team
so to wrap up uh three really simple
takeaways
first and foremost recognize the value
and effort that these are random
variables and what we need to do is we
need to estimate these
so spend your initial time estimating
those before deciding what work to do
build up to that in iterative fashions
um
we have a very great algorithmic
approach which is just do a little bit
of steps right work broadly don't go
very deep avoid greedy algorithms get as
much information as possible take a few
steps in order to understand the value
and effort and then really decide on the
one or two massive projects you're going
to take on
and most importantly we must be
responsible for our work getting used
this is a really challenging one
especially again for folks in data so
many times I've heard folks say well I'm
going to produce I'm going to make this
model I'm going to do this analysis I'm
going to give it to them whether or not
they do anything with it I can't control
that that's up to them of which yes
that's totally true this is not
something you can control once you've
already handed it off once you're done
with the work this is something that
gets controlled before you decide to
start doing the work so before you start
doing the work you have to figure out
how is it going to be used and we have
to be responsible for that to make sure
that our work actually makes it all the
way through to so someone can use it
and that is about it a little bit over
time but thank you all very much for
your time today appreciate it